you're right you say you start to say
I'm okay and then it's yeah and then
they hear you dude they hear you I'll
kill you
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Pedro Pascal he's
an actor you know from a string of
massive Global hits up in the last
decade including Game of Thrones narcos
the Mandalorian HBO's brand new
record-breaking show The Last of Us and
more good news for Pedro Pascal fans is
the much anticipated third season of the
Mandalorian begins streaming on Disney
plus March 1st Pedro Pascal welcome to
the show
thank you for having me I'm so glad for
the opportunity to finally be taken
seriously how are you around spicy food
before we get started
I mean I was really good around spicy
food as a Young Man
and young internal organs
um I don't know if it goes so great
anymore we'll find out there's only one
way to find out are you ready to get
started in front of
millions of people
foreign
[Music]
okay
let me
[Music]
I wonder how much of this is going to
get caught on my
astonishing mustache
[Music]
good
wow
I did Skip breakfast
it's on your latest project The Last of
Us who played the role of Joel Miller a
character who much like the show has
this austere outer shell but Underneath
It All is a Warmness as an actor how do
you think about balancing the noble
traits that make a character like Joel
heroic versus the weaker ones that make
him human
you're smart
I never thought about it that way
um
I think that
there's a funny thing about a very sort
of restricted exterior that is typical
for
um these kinds of male archetypes I
think
don't show your feelings people will see
that you're weak survival is key don't
let anybody in you know
developing human connection is is not at
least in his mind key to survival but
then only to discover that he cannot
live without it at any cost
[Music]
this one's kind of like colorful
split the is
look at those mechanics yeah baby oh
not new to the chicken wing game
[Music]
my brothers are so jealous
I brought him because he he was like you
gotta do hot wings been telling me for
like six years
oh thank you by the way for the referral
I think he just wants chicken wings
lovely I will save the I want to dive I
wanna
clean the bone on the other one but I'm
gonna Pace myself smart smart play smart
play and I can revisit
what blew your mind the most about the
mechanics of grogu's performance you
know where you have one technician who's
doing eyes and mouth and then another
technician simultaneously doing the
facial expressions there's two of them
and one there's like remote and you can
carry him around
um he'll like just move ahead his his
head will move around ears you know what
I mean like turn towards you as you're
holding him and stuff like that and kind
of be alive
and then for a good close-up he is
connected to
you know the Pentagon like it's like
these wires that um enclose like you
know then that's where you get the
really detailed eyebrow movements and
eyeballs kind of moving around and he's
a very cooperative and fulfilling scene
partner acting partner you know it's
pretty crazy like having to say goodbye
to him in season two and
getting praise for oh my gosh like you
know you you you have such subtle
emotion and you're dealing with a puppet
and I'm like this puppet is making me
cry right you know it's like no you know
you know I fully and I'm like damn
chill you're stealing it
it's like the one time I have my helmet
off like let me let me have the scene
bro
I can see it looks like some kind of
angry mole rat rabbit
[Music]
this is kind of the first little jump I
feel like we take
it doesn't jump it creeps yeah yeah
lingers a little bit grows a little bit
yeah
smaller bites but it is really good
that's how it goes it's tasty
you just keep talking I'm hungry sure
what role did the South Coast Repertory
in Costa Mesa play in uh shaping your
affection for acting at a young age
how the hell did you find out about the
South Coast Repertory you're the first
person to ask me that was in Orange
County my mom this is the best
we moved from Texas to California
and I was going still with this sort of
like diluted fantasy of wanting to be an
actor and knowing that if we were moving
to Southern California that was like
just one big giant leap towards
Hollywood
and my mom was like I'll find you
something like at the local community
theater
I was on the younger side and then there
was like on the old you know there was
like maybe some 14 year olds some
teenagers
they were a little badass and
stuck me a cigarette and we got caught
that kind of stuff yeah it's starting to
get with the theater kids
you know the rebels
[Music]
good it's like
it's a little sweet when's it gonna hurt
you know what this one I think might be
a little bit of a shift down yeah you
know that's what it feels like yeah
enjoy those enjoy those valleys you know
good job there we go here we go
when you're watching other movies or
other TV shows do you ever think about
like an actor's wardrobe and how heavy
or uncomfortable it might be because I
feel like you do have a unique Insight
you know working with heavy armor heavy
suits weapons and the like it's a
terrible thing in terms of my experience
being such a consumer of movies and
television and such a little Fanboy and
now
because of the context
I really my family wants to kill me so
much of the time because I'm just like
I've been eating that mud all over his
body he's freezing
oh my gosh that's so cool that's a lot
of blood that's a lot of blood that's
very sticky you know I'm so hyper aware
about what the crew and the cast is
going through and everyone wants to kill
me
I'm like those shoes
get blisters no shoes
[Music]
it's a little intimidating okay
oh yeah yeah time release it's a it's
the emergence
of yeah that's good because you're like
oh that's spicy I should have another
bite
it's tasty but when it's good that's
what you have to do you know yeah
what's good
all right we're okay we're doing all
right we've got our feet yeah
still got our feet
[Music]
what are the mechanics of shooting a
scene where your character has his eyes
gouged out of his skull you know that's
happened to you on two separate
occasions and of course the
unforgettable death in Game of Thrones
but then that final scene of equalizer
too
um maybe in this interview as well time
only time I could beg you to gouge my
eyes out and uh collapse my skull in
case it gets really bad
um
I got my head crushed in it was the best
part of the day it was so hot when we
were shooting that scene you know he's
over me and he puts his thumbs into my
eyes and they've got piping uh tubing
piping through his uh body into his
forearms forearms to his thumbs and just
like pumping this like cool blood
and um so gentle like the gentlest guy
ever felt no pressure at all you know
and he was so hyper aware of it he
couldn't even feel his weight on me as
he like you know basically straddled me
there were all of these
fleshy bits that they were
kind of placing all over my face and
pumping blood so that it would pool you
know and spread through the amphitheater
for this like good wide and that sort of
shot of the two of us from above I was
dead asleep
because it was like it was so hot and
this stuff was so cooling to the touch
and you had to be really really still
and that was the most relaxing and
knowing also that we had gotten to the
end of this sort of four day fight that
we were shooting out there
um it was a very uh cathartic and I went
into the deepest sleep I've I've been in
I I I realize now that because I'm not a
very good sleeper I need I need to be
laid out with pieces of Flesh
um gelatinous cool to the touch uh
face meat
and uh pulling blood and maybe I'll
finally get a good [__] night's sleep
[Music]
mushroom Mayhem okay
together forever forever forever bonded
funk
[Music]
is it true that all the cast on the set
of the unbearable weight of massive
Talent was gifted a Nicholas Cage pillow
each one signed by Nicolas Cage
I think I remember kind of hiding these
pillows from him
I was like you're not ready
you get him to sign this pillow for me
I'm like no no no no he's not ready he's
not ready he doesn't want to see it and
then I think we all got them at the end
I can um
the the
[Music]
torture mushroom sauce is starting to um
torture would like to be a part of this
conversation he doesn't want to talk he
doesn't want me to talk about Nicholas
Cage's pillows
my character had this collector's room
of everything from his movies and a
life-size model of him from face often
he put this pillow in the scene
you wanted to get rid of it
and I said no
um I think it should stay and then he
was like fine so he'll play
and he points to it he's like uh
that that that's weird and I was any any
like painted it changed his face and I
was like no it's nice and I put it back
and they kept it in the movie that was
definitely an improvised moment
the one the one time I was uh uh
disagreeing with him
[Music]
it's so great to finally lose your mind
angry angry goat pepper that's what's
there
[Music]
I don't feel anything
maybe that's nice yeah you know let's
not step on it let's go if we got a
freebie okay we take it yeah you haven't
lost a step I haven't lost a step
thank you bro I see I see I see I see I
see it's all about time release with
these guys yeah yeah yeah right
or you talk about them in a
complimentary way and then they bite
it's almost like they can hear you right
talking about them you know just let me
love you
and then I know that you're a fan of
Nicholas Cage long before you start
alongside him yeah do you have a Mount
Rushmore of Nicolas Cage movies
and I can throw some at you no no you
don't have to throw any okay
okay
um
the earlier ones for me because of how
impressionable they are but Raising
Arizona
Peggy Sue got married
um Face-Off classic
I got a soft spot for Moonstruck man and
it isn't even about having a big swing
in terms of performance it is actually
highly highly intelligent
Choice making in his acting where I'm
gonna do like a Fritz laying hand thing
in the moment where I scream about my
brother Danny Aiello
um accidentally chopping his hand off he
looked away and dropped it he's like I
lost my hand and we and it is just to
this
perfect effect where it's grounded in
the scene has all of this theatrical
context to it and concept he's still
believable
it was really amazing to do homework for
that movie and re-watch all these movies
that I'd already seen so many times
um adaptation is maybe one of the best
screen performances in the history of
American Cinema but the four that I
mentioned have
you know a personal place in my
development
as
uh an aspiring actor and to this day in
My DNA a little bit where I realize that
I
I'm doing something and I'm saying
something in a way that I have to stop
and take a second and realize oh I got
that from Vampire's Kiss or something
you know
all right yes this next one is the bomb
Beyond Insanity because I ate this one
already yep that was the dreams of
calypso the bomb Beyond Insanity yeah
I kind of clear my throat before this
one too yeah this will clear our throats
for us yeah and everything else okay
all right this one's dangerous we're not
driving noon
that well oh no
no no no no no no no no
that's a jump
significant exponential this is a story
structure to your interview yeah yeah we
have a whole article you do you you tell
me I'm you tell me I'm I'm doing well
yeah and then you try to kill me yeah
yeah well I see I mean it's got to be
successful for a reason
yeah and
and you know this is part I really
actually got to the point where I
thought that this might not happen
stop talking
it comes for all of us this one
I might do that too that's a good move
actually
can somebody step in here and let me
bite into their flesh
cup of blood
[Music]
yeah did you ever see the fly am I
talking really loud yeah do you feel
like
you're going through a metamorphosis the
fly with Jeff Goldblum yeah classic and
he vomits onto the guy's hand and it
just dissolves and disintegrates and
then there's just like this little piece
of Flesh that's being like that's my
mouth yeah
do I have a tongue it's still there it's
still there you might not be able to
feel it but it's still there [__]
hate milk but any port in a storm you
know
what makes Captain Crunch the top dog of
breakfast cereals for you
[Music]
Mark resourceful yeah
um
Captain Crunch is just so tasty
it tastes like what is that taste it's
like caramel yeah yeah it's kind of its
own thing you know it's its own thing
it's like
um you know
makes you think about your childhood
and I would do anything to go back there
right now
well speaking of your childhood as
somebody who grew up in San Antonio can
you break down the difference between
good Tex-Mex and bad Tex-Mex um
very good question now it's time to make
people angry
I'm doing okay yeah right yeah it's like
a wave yeah exactly the worst is fine
the worst is over really it's behind us
don't spit back up none of it is allowed
to come back into my mouth
you're right you said you start to say
I'm okay and then yeah and then they
hear you dude they hear you I'll kill
you
so um there's a second wave
my God
[Music]
I was in Southern California and I I at
that point you know Mexican food Tex-Mex
and I come to New York
for 20 years people are like no this
place is good Mexican and I'm just like
no it's not
it's not
there's no good Mexican food in
New York
come for me
um do I have a lot of uh liquefied mucus
coming out of my nose you know what you
you have like sort of a Wingate shine
that I've come to recognize I'm sure I
got the same thing going on but it's
just kind of a glow if anything you know
you look great you look great
thank you
this next one is Taco Vibes only Taco
Vibes only
butterfly Bakery of Vermont how bad
could Vermont be right
okay
has anybody ever projectile vomited
during your turn no you could break new
ground really
I just feel like there's tingles that I
didn't even know there were I I'm
learning about where all my nerve
endings are around my lips it's full um
MRI scan over here look at you going in
though
okay Vermont
they know it doesn't really matter
because my mouth is dead exactly
okay
thinking back early on in your career
when you do guest spots on shows like
NYPD Blue Law and Order CSI was there a
role that stands out in your memory
because it was like maybe an unusually
complicated character or like unusually
fun to play
um there was a really really unusually
fun character that I played on NYPD Blue
this goth guy named Dio
and he had a you know he got all these
like fake piercings and just teenager
and he's hitting on the on the female
cop
at one point
he has a a pentagram
on the inside of his palm that they made
with like a black Sharpie
and I lick it
and I make up some satanic language and
I thought you know that it's supposed to
be like Latin or something
and I remember thinking well what do you
do you have like do you have Latin words
that I'm supposed to learn and they're
like oh dude
just make it up I was like oh okay
it was the kind of thing was like you
know I like that I licked the hand and
then I turned slowly towards the camera
going
to talk about you know some crazy [__]
like that on an episode of your ABC
Network television hit NYPD Blue I made
up the language and they can't take that
away from you they can't they can't take
that one away from you what are you
doing with that
[Music]
foreign
how much did you put on
is this as bad as the bomb
nothing's as bad as the bomb all right
get it good there you go that's perfect
I need people to like me you know what I
mean
very if not what's it all for you know
exactly what the hell is this all for
eign
[Music]
to a point I understand I get it
feeling it out
looks like we're in a good place though
yeah I know
[Music]
look at you
oh good
all right Pedro Pascal to close things
out you know we talked about how the
scene how the cinema was a place that
you and your family could soak in pop
culture but I know that another
formative experience for you was seeing
live concerts you know the first show
that you went to with Iggy Pop and the
police all the way go ahead let that go
let that go
all the way to curling your lip and
Performing Billy Idol in the mirror so
to close things out my question to you
is this with your brain on fire and
mouth Ablaze why is Prince's Purple Rain
the song you'd most want to hear at your
funeral
it's my favorite song
it's the most moving song
I don't know why it always emerges even
before I actively just started
implementing it into my spiritual
routine essentially I didn't go to
church
I was raised by HBO Spielberg and Prince
and um for me
Purple Rain is like the most emotionally
cathartic the most musically
sophisticated song that I can think of
if it's casually or spontaneously
playing
somewhere
um
I I I'm like I'm not
I don't have emotional space
to go there
because it just moves me so deeply
and what a way to go out and look at you
taking on the wings of death and still
living to tell the tale we could hold
off on that funeral Pedro Pascal now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you live another day
this camera this camera this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life what do I have going okay
um I would say that there's a there's a
gap in between my back molar and my
front tooth that's where the chicken
gets stuck and it continues to sort of
burn but I've gotten to the point
you should know this too
that I'm I'm used to the sensation of
um my jaw having been melted away by uh
battery acid Maybe
and um and and then I think I'm gonna go
to the Whitney Museum this afternoon
unless I uh [__] myself
goodbye
[Applause]
it's so good
[Music]
do you wanna do you want to feel like
real wet yeah like that's wet oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like
full-on tears that come from the side of
your head well it won't be in vain
because you crushed it
a button back up
such a great show thanks for having me
oh man I feel like I'm finally cool to
people that I care about the most about
[Music]
hot ones fans exciting news the season
20 hot ones 10 pack is now available if
you've ever watched from home and
wondered to yourself how hot are the
wings really or been one of those people
that's like oh they're only taking one
bite well you know what if you think you
could do better now is the time to put
your money where your mouth is literally
with the hot ones season 20 10 pack
available exclusively at heatness.com
that's heatness.com heatness.com
heatness.com to get your hands on the
season 20 hot ones 10 pack
get them while they're high foreign
[Music]
[Applause]